major controversy because of something I
posted to my Instagram account yesterday
of course i'm on instagram at david
pakman some people people are telling me
that that they enjoy following my post
on instagram i posted a picture well
let's start first with my new swimming
goggles picture
I do sometimes swim Pat and I recently
bought new swimming goggles because I
wanted I open my eyes underwater and
because I wear contact lenses I want
goggles to protect my eyes underwater I
don't know what would happen to the
contact underwater without goggles but I
don't want to find out and I posted a
picture of me with my new goggles and
comments saying that I look like an
alien and of course no shortage of
anti-semitic comments I don't know how
goggles relate to Judaism but apparently
they do and that that's that I mean no
no's loaded I think they're very spiffy
and do you plan on wearing them in your
kitchen often not often I'm not often
just in this picture depends on what I'm
cooking yeah if I'm making like a soup
where there might be a lot of splashing
oh yeah maybe if I'm using an immersion
blender or something like that then I
might I might wear the goggles in the
kitchen but for the most part these will
be for the pool and then this is what
really set people off in preparation for
my trip to my birth country of Argentina
next month I went through I have like a
bag of leftover foreign currency I've
got some euros in there and some Israeli
shekels and whatever British pounds and
I have some Argentinian pesos there and
I found that I had 70 Argentinian pesos
and I've posted to my Instagram account
you know these 70 Argentinean pesos when
I was last in Argentina were worth about
eleven dollars and because of the
devaluation of Argentinian currency
these same 70 pesos own that are now
only worth four dollars in the 13 cents
and immediately the Argentinians who
follow me came out of the woodwork
saying David that's toilet paper and
this is a line I know it's not just
Argentina that does this but because
Argentina has had currency issues for a
very long time I grew up with basically
toilet paper is an interchangeable name
for Argentinian currency and that that's
exactly the situation now however a lot
of people believe that it's laugh
probably cheap to go to Argentina as a
result you see it's like a nearly 17 to
1 peso $2 exchange rate so it must be
super cheap no the the economy is so out
of control there that inflation is such
that even with a 17 to 1 exchange rate
it still as expensive as Boston or New
York ok which is completely unaffordable
on Argentinian salaries I should tell
you see initially I was reminded of the
Weimar Republic where the German mark
was devalued so much that people use it
as insulation or kindling for fires or
because it was just practically
worthless yeah and that's not I mean I
guess I don't know what the exchange
rate was then compared what's going on
in Argentina but people aren't burning
the money right now but people do use it
toward it sort of to mop up if you if
you spill tea or coffee the equivalent
of $4 you can still buy something nice
with $4 yep I could I can get half of a
coffee yeah no but in all seriousness
people told me that if you go to a
coffee shop and you get a coffee and a
croissant that it's about eight US
dollars which is expensive even by
American standards in a country where
the average annual wage is I don't know
offhand but it's not a lot it's I think
it's like eight eight thousand US
dollars a year or something like that
should be an interesting trip well let's
let's put it that way